Okay, so good morning. Uh
today we're doing the Russian Empire.
And to review, we've done
America and Britain so far, and we
discussed industrialization. Today we'll
do Russia, and then on Thursday we'll
start Germany.
Um let's simplify the differences
between these three great modern
civilizations that are struggling for
world domination even today.
So, as we discussed last week,
um
the defining characteristics of the
Anglo-American civilization is their
belief in utilitarianism, okay? They
want They want to know what is
practical, what works.
Um their idea of Christianity is the
supreme God is a force that elects. And
what this means is
that
um not everyone will go to heaven. Only
a minority will go to heaven. And this
minority are those who have proven
themselves the most worthy, okay? The
last idea of the Anglo-American
civilization is that the meaning of life
is the pursuit of life, liberty, and
happiness. Essentially, the pursuit of
wealth, okay? So, that these are the
um characteristics of the Anglo-American
civilization.
Um on Thursday we'll start the German
German civilization. And what you will
um see is that the Germans are very
different. Um they're not utilitarians.
They're very idealistic, very romantic.
Um for them, God is a force that demands
you to be your very best.
Okay? Not a few people, but everyone.
And the Germans believe in the unity of
will, okay? Everyone has to work
together and promote German
civilization. Today we do the Russians,
okay? And the Russians are a very
different civilization.
Uh first of all, they're much more
fatalistic than the Germans and the
Americans. They don't believe that you
have control over your life. They
believe that you can only accept what is
given to you and make the most out of
it.
Um for them, God is a force that redeems
and saves all. God is merciful. God is
forgiving, okay? This is a very
different conception from both the
German and the Anglo-American
conception. The last concept that we
will look at today is for them,
the um essence of life is to understand
the mystery, miracle, and authority of
the human heart.
Okay? So, whereas the Americans and
British place their emphasis on science,
on mastering the world, um
uh the material world, and whereas the
Germans are extremely idealistic, they
want an understanding of
existence, the Russians are focused very
much on the human heart, okay? For the
Russians, the greatest mystery,
um the most knowledge is within the
human heart. And this is what we will
focus on
uh today.
Okay. So, um the leading question for
today's class, the question that I'm
sure you're all interested in is why did
Putin invade Ukraine? What is driving
the Russian invasion of Ukraine? And um
there are lots of easy explanations.
What I will show you today is the answer
is actually extremely complicated. What
Putin himself has said in multiple
interviews is there are historical
um sociological, philosophical issues at
work here.
And Russians don't really understand
what he's saying, okay? So, what I'm
going to do today is I'm going to
explain to you what he really means.
Okay.
So, um if you look at the year 1300,
um you could not expect Moscow to
eventually become the Russian Empire. At
this point in history, the Mongols have
controlled most of the world, and
Moscow, along with other areas
um in the um empire, they were vassal
states, okay? They paid taxes, they paid
tribute, they provided troops to the
Mongol Empire, but it's the Mongol
Empire that is the um great power at
this stage.
So, but So, why But if you look at
history, okay? You'll see a very similar
pattern where it's not really the
greatest power that will eventually uh
overwhelm everyone. It's always the
marginal power, okay? So,
going back to and reviewing what we've
learned so far, remember when we
discussed the Aztecs, the Aztecs were
very much a poor, isolated um backward
people,
um but eventually, through innovation,
through tenacity, through resilience,
they will come to conquer most of
Central America. Same thing with the
Qing Dynasty in China, right? At this
stage in history, maybe 300, 400 BCE,
you would not expect the Qing Empire uh
the Qing Dynasty to overwhelm all of
China and become China's first great
national empire. Maybe the Chu, maybe
the Wei, Qi, they're all stronger at
this point in history, but it's the
marginal uh power that seems weak at
first that will overwhelm. Same thing
with Macedon, okay? At this point in
history, in the year uh 400, 300 uh BCE,
it's Athens, Sparta,
uh Thebes that are powers, but
eventually, Macedon will not only
will not only overwhelm the Greek
peninsula, but they will go over to
Persia and conquer the Persian Empire as
well. Same thing with Rome. Rome um at
this point in history, maybe 500 BCE, it
is the weakest of all these Italian
states. Um the uh Etruscans are the main
power, and they are the poorest, the
weakest, the smallest of all these great
tribes, but eventually, over uh the next
centuries, they will conquer everyone.
Same thing with the Franks. Um after the
Roman Empire, the Franks will slowly
expand from Central Europe and overwhelm
uh most of Europe to create the Holy
Roman Empire. Okay? And the same thing
with the Prussians. Uh next class we
will discuss the Prussian Empire, which
becomes modern-day Germany. They start
off as this landlocked um
um
isolated central area within
uh
Europe, but eventually, they will spread
out to conquer all of
uh Germany, okay? So,
the lessons we can learn from uh these
case studies is there are three forces
that drive these marginalized powers to
become the great power of the day, okay?
So, for Moscow, it's a constant process
of creative destruction. First of all,
open cooperative competition. So,
they're always surrounded by these
adversaries, and because they don't
really lack and because they don't have
natural defenses, they don't have
mountains, rivers, um
it forces them to be tough and unified
in order to defeat their enemies. And
it's toughness and unity that will allow
Moscow to emerge as a great power
um in Central Asia.
Advantage by disadvantages, okay? You're
better off being weak, because if you're
weak, it forces you to be innovative and
open, okay? So, they say
um necessity is the mother of invention.
The last factor is vassalage, okay? So,
the idea that historical humiliation and
subjection force reflection and
resilience. Because Moscow, for the
longest time, was subjected
um to vassals by the Mongols, it forced
them to be humble, and humility allows
you to reflect deeply on your own
weaknesses, to be honest with yourself,
and eventually triumph over all your
adversaries, okay? So, these are the
three factors that will drive the
massive expansion of Moscow, okay?
Moscow starts off as this very small
principality within the Mongol Empire,
and then it will eventually become the
successor to the Mongol Empire.
All right.
Um so, let's look at the origins of the
uh
of Russia. So, the history is
we have to go back to the Viking Age,
right? This This is about the year 900,
1000,
right? So, the Vikings are in
uh Sweden and Denmark and Norway. And
because it's so poor and because it's
becoming overly populated, um they will
start to expand over to England, to
Greenland, to other areas. And then So,
can you open the door? Uh and then that
they will
also move east, okay? Why are they
moving east? Because all the great
wealth of of the age is located in the
Byzantine Empire, in Egypt, and as well
as the Abbasid Empire um in Iraq and
Persia, okay?
So, they
they're here to establish trading posts.
And when they establish trading posts,
what will happen is that first of all,
they will intermarry with the local
Slavic population as well as the um
steppe people, okay? They will also
build an alliance with the Byzantine
Empire and become basically vassals to
the Byzantines.
All right?
Um
What will happen is over time, their
trading posts will become cities, and
they will expand
outwards. So, the tradition, the custom
at at this stage in history is
if you're noble
um you must go and conquer new lands.
When you conquer new lands, you're going
to enslave the people to work for you.
Okay, this is a very feudal system.
Okay? So, this forces a process of
constant expansion. If they don't
expand, they're going to fight amongst
themselves. So, the Kievan Rus expands
very quickly throughout this
uh area.
Um
eventually, they'll all be conquered by
the Mongols. And when the Mongols leave,
it leaves a vacuum of great powers,
okay? So, the great power of this age is
the Grand Duchy of Lithuania, okay?
Um Novgorod is also a great power.
Moscow is the weakest, but again, as I
said, over time, because it is weak,
it's forced to be united, it's forced to
be resilient, it's forced to be
innovative. And over time, what it will
do is it will overwhelm
uh Novgorod and become the Russian
Empire.
Okay? And as you can see, what will
happen is the Russian Empire will expand
really quickly until it absorbs the
entire
uh Mongol Empire as well as unify all of
um northern Asia, okay? It is now the
largest landmass in the world.
Okay. Um so,
um the thing to understand about the
Russians is that even though it's a very
uh
large country most of it is not able to
be cultivated, okay? So, that it has
very uh low population. Most of the
wealth is located in the in over here,
okay? This is basically Ukraine.
This is what's driving the invasion,
because historically, most of the wealth
uh in Russia has been located in the
Ukraine area.
And if you over here, it's basically
just forests and mountains. So, why are
they moving
uh
eastwards when there's very little
resources here? The answer is fur, okay?
Fur. Uh fur is a very valuable
commodity. They go and they uh
they trade fur for a living.
Okay. Um some of the great tsars of
Russian history is Ivan the Great. And
his son is Ivan the Terrible, who will
expand Russia
uh greatly, okay? Um the thing to
understand about Russian expansion is
it's really not driven by state policy,
it's really driven by oppression and
misery. And what this means is that
because Russia is essentially a feudal
state, the only way to build a better
life is if you escape eastwards and you
basically ethnic ethnically cleanse that
area and build a new settlement, okay?
So, that's what's driving this. And what
will happen is as these people move
further eastwards, the state will follow
them in order to collect taxes, okay?
And sometimes, the state will
intervene in order to protect these
people from uh their adversaries in the
local areas. But it's a very brutal
process that takes centuries. And the
Russians win out because uh there's more
of them and also because they have
muskets and the local people do not have
muskets.
Okay. So, as you can see, the expansion
is very rapid, only approximately 300
years.
Um and as I mentioned, it is an
extremely brutal process. Okay, so these
are paintings of uh the brutality
involved in this eastward expansion. It
involves ethnic cleansing. It involves
enslaving people, okay?
Yeah, it's a brutal process. And these
paintings are meant to capture the
brutality of the process.
And you can see the misery involved.
Okay, so these people who are being
conquered, they're either being
ethnically cleansed or they're being
forced to immigrate or they're being
enslaved.
Um it's a very similar process with the
Americans.
Um and these will eventually come become
the two great empires um of the 20th
century as well as really the 21st
century, okay? So, the Americans have
the same situation where they're
expanding westwards and the Russians are
expanding eastwards. The difference is
this. The Americans are expanding
westwards for better opportunities,
okay? To build up to to get wealthy, to
build a better life. The Russians are
are expanding eastwards because they are
trying to escape misery and oppression
and slavery. Okay, that's the
difference. And because of this
difference, even though there are there
are many
similarities, the fundamental
belief systems of these two nations are
very different. Americans are
fundamentally optimistic.
But Russians are fundamentally
fatalistic, pessimistic, okay?
All right. Um so, let's
summarize the differences between
the Slavic East, the Russian East, and
the Germanic West, okay? Uh Slavic gives
us the word slave. Why? Because for the
longest time, the Slavs in Europe, in
Eastern Europe, they were pagans. They
weren't Muslims, they weren't
Christians. And the custom at that time
is you can only enslave people who are
not of your religious belief, okay?
Okay? So, the pagans were the most
valuable people because they can be they
can be be enslaved by everyone. So,
Vikings came, uh the Muslims came, the
Christians came to enslave the Slavic
people and sell them off to the
Byzantines, the Abbasids, um and that's
why we get the word slave, okay? So,
let's look at the three major
differences between Russia and Germany.
The first major difference is that
the Russians believe they are heirs to
the Byzantine Empire, which is a very
top-down, centralized bureaucracy. And
this is something we discussed uh
before. The Germans uh believe they are
heirs to the Holy Roman Empire, which is
a confederation,
okay? As we discussed when we discussed
the Holy Roman Empire, it was impossible
for anyone to conquer all of Europe. And
so, um the Holy Roman Empire was based
on consensus. It was based on diplomacy.
Okay, it was based on intermarriage. So,
this is a much more democratic, much
more
uh independent system than the
Byzantines. Second major difference is
the Germans have the Catholic Church,
the Russians have something called the
Eastern Orthodox Church. This sounds
similar, but what I will show you as we
move on is it's actually night and day,
okay? These two belief systems are
extremely different.
Third major difference is um
Germanic West, the Germans, they are
culturally coherent. They believe they
speak the same language, they believe
that they come from the same culture,
whereas the Russian Empire, it is
culturally incoherent, okay? It uh
encompasses a vast array of different
cultures, languages,
uh and belief systems.
All right.
Okay. So, the Russian Empire starts with
Peter the Great.
And what Peter the Great does is he
modernizes Russia
and forces
a decisive war with Sweden, which is at
Europe right now, the great military
power.
Okay, so for most of Russian history,
the European powers didn't really take
Russia seriously.
And they just thought that the Russians
are part of Asia, they're really not
part of Europe.
And it was Peter the Great who was
determined to westernize, Europeanize
Russia and prove Russia a European
power.
Okay? And he does that
um for three reasons, all right? Let's
Oh, sorry, sorry. For many reasons,
okay?
He does it because
Russia right now is an empire. And as an
empire, you need a unifying ideology, a
philosophy. And for the Russians for the
longest time, even Putin shares this
philosophy, is they believe they are
trying to restore the Byzantine Empire
and be the third Rome and save
civilization. Okay, so so what do I mean
by this? All right. So, the first Rome,
of course, was Rome. Second Rome was
Constantinople. The third Rome now is
Moscow.
And not only that, but they believe
they are the true heirs to the Christian
tradition. All these other Christian
religions out there, Catholic,
Protestant, they are corrupt forms. It's
the Orthodox Church that's the true heir
to the Roman uh Christianity. All right?
Um quest for military supremacy means
that right now at this stage in history,
all the great um militaries are in
Europe, okay? So,
you're Russia basically needs to copy,
imitate uh the Europeans. So, what So,
what Russia does is it imports a lot of
actually German soldiers and mercenaries
to learn German military technique.
Quest for absolute power means that all
these tsars, Peter the Great, Catherine
the Great, they're in they're interested
in centralizing authority. They want to
remove this feudal system and centralize
power in all in their hands.
Okay? Dilution of authority of church
and nobility.
So, uh in Europe, the Catholic Church is
above
the kings,
okay? So, Peter the Great wants to
subject the church to his authority as
well as the nobility. Uh right now, the
great
threat, the great rival to the Russians
is the Ottoman Empire,
okay? And And last is the contempt of
Asia, okay? So, um even though the
Mongols probably influenced the Russians
much more than the Vikings, the Russians
believe the Vikings are their true
um
um ancestors, not the Mongols. They try
to They try to erase the Mongols from
their own history. They're kind of
ashamed of it.
Okay. So, again,
as I mentioned, at this time in Europe,
about the year 1700, Sweden is the great
military power of the age. And Peter the
Great and Charles the 12th of Sweden,
they get in this major conflict. And
Peter the Great is not that great, okay?
He He has a lot of issues. But Charles
the Second is a complete disaster. And
the reason why is he's a young man. He's
only about 27 when he invades Russia,
who fancies himself as Alexander the
Great. Okay? And as we discussed,
Alexander the Great was very problematic
because he was very tyrannical, and also
because he believed he was invincible.
So, Charles the Great decides to go
invade Russia.
And this is a disaster. Why? Because
Peter the Great will
use something called a scorched earth
policy. Basically, he knows that he
cannot on the battlefield defeat the
Swedes. So, what the Russians do is they
retreat and burn down all the fields so
the army cannot feed itself. Okay? This
is called scorched earth. And this is
important because
this is how the Russians will defeat
Napoleon in 1812. And this is important
because that's how the Russians will
defeat the Germans in World War II,
okay? So, this is very This is a very
familiar pattern in history.
Um
as I mentioned, the great enemy of
Russia at this time are the Ottomans,
okay? And so, the Russians and the
Ottomans will clash over the
Crimea, okay? The Crimea.
And this will lead to something called
the Crimean War
in 1854.
Okay. So, Peter the Great, again, he
wins because
Charles the Second
makes disastrous military decisions
during this war. But this is This begins
the Russian Empire, okay? For the first
time, Russia is now considered a great
European power because it's defeated the
great military power of Europe, Sweden.
Okay. So, these are paintings
celebrating the great Russian victory
over the Swedes. So, after this victory,
Russia will expand very greatly.
And then, after the Peter the Great,
the next great Westernizer of the
Russian Empire is Catherine the Great.
What's important for us to remember
about Catherine the Great is she's
actually not Russian. She's actually
German. She She was born in Prussia, and
she married into the Russian noble
family. It was very common at this stage
for the European powers to intermarry
with each other. And most of the
Russian nobility, a lot of them actually
have German blood. And they actually
spoke French at home. Okay? So, so this
Westernization created a process where
the nobility now is very European. They
speak French, they have German ancestry,
and the
the peasants are Slavic, okay? And so,
this creates a massive divide in Russia.
Catherine the Great will extend
Russia
greatly, as you can see from this map.
The great
event
that basically thrust Russia as a great
power is the defeat of Napoleon in 1812.
Napoleon, as we know, the great
conqueror, he invades Russia in 1812.
And
he defeats the Russian army, but what
the Russians do that no one can possibly
imagine they would do is they burn down
the capital, Moscow. Okay? Moscow is the
cultural capital. It is the heart and
soul of the Russian Empire. And they
burn it down to starve Napoleon's army.
And the Europeans thought this was
a incredible act of barbarism. Okay? But
for the Russians, they believed it was
an incredible act of
self-sacrifice
that saved the Russian Empire. In fact,
the great Russian composer, he wrote a
symphony dedicated to
celebrating the victory over Napoleon,
called the 1812 Overture.
Have you guys
heard the overture? All right. Let me
Let me play it for you, okay?
I'm pretty sure you heard it before.
So, Charles
fought back by defeating Napoleon by
making the sacrifice. They not only
saved Russia, but they saved all of
Europe. They saved Western civilization,
basically.
Okay.
Okay. So, I'm sure you you guys have
heard of it, right? Okay. But this is to
celebrate the defeat of Napoleon by
Tchaikovsky.
Okay.
Um
after the defeat of Napoleon, though,
the Europeans take notice of Russia,
especially Britain. Remember, Britain is
this great naval power that is dedicated
to a divide and conquer policy of of
Europe. They basically gang up against
whoever is the growing power in Europe.
So, if
as Russia is growing,
the British encourage the Ottomans and
the French to unite against Russia to
prevent Russia expansion into the
Ottoman Empire. Eventually, the Russians
will defeat the Ottoman Empire, but the
Crimean War is a major setback for the
Russians. And this creates something
called the Great Game, where the
Russians
are now being held in by the by the
British, okay? So, the British and the
Russians now will not will not fight for
supremacy over Central Asia.
A disaster The next disaster for the for
the Russians is the Russo-Japanese War,
where Russia gets heavily defeated by
the Japanese, and this
sort of instigates revolutionary
sentiment and fever in Russia. And of
course, what follows next is the great
disaster, the First War, where the
Russians are defeated mightily by the
Germans, and this creates something
called the 1917 Bolshevik Revolution,
which destroys the Russian Empire and
creates the
uh Soviet Empire, okay?
So, this is just a brief history. We'll
go into the revolution at a future date,
okay? It's a very important event, and I
I want to dedicate a whole class to it.
But that's a brief background of the
Russian Empire. Okay.
So, now let's talk about the
civilization. And as I discussed,
Westernization has
has been a major trend in Europe. But
because of Westernization, there are
three major contradictions
that are created within the Russian
Empire, okay? And these three
contradictions will go on to create
Russian civilization, okay? These
contradictions are it's both European
and Central Asian, okay? It's both
Viking and Mongol. It's both It's both
Slavic as well as Tatar, okay? So,
there's a lot of ethnicities, a lot of
cultures within Russia, and it's a
contradiction.
Second contradiction is it fancies
itself as a Christian Orthodox nation.
In fact, the true Christian nation. It's
also very pagan.
Remember, there's this massive eastward
expansion in the process, there's
a lot of war. There's a lot of violence,
okay? It's very pagan. And the
peasantry,
even to this day, maintain a lot of
pagan rituals, a lot of pagan beliefs.
The third
great contradiction is between
enlightenment and empire. So, Catherine
the Great, who was Prussian, she tried
to saw herself as an enlightened
monarch. She was best friends with
Voltaire. They didn't They never met,
but they were pen pals. And she saw
herself as an enlightened despot, who
was trying to bring reason and justice
and goodness to Russia. Okay? But at the
same time, it's an empire, and it's a
brutal empire that
and the Russians engage in a lot of
barbarism, okay? So, this is also a
massive contradiction.
And so, if you study Russian
civilization,
okay? It is unique because of these
three major contradictions. So, let me
show you how they influence Russian art
and literature. Okay.
Let's look at some of the major Russian
cultural figures.
And
there are too many to name, okay?
There's just a lot of them, but I'll
just go through the most famous.
This is Alexander Pushkin,
who is considered the Shakespeare of
Russia. He's the great innovator of
Russian language. He basically
modernizes the language. And he's a poet
and a very romantic figure in Russia.
He's basically the national poet of
Russia. Something really interesting
about him is his grandfather was an
African general, who
who was
who became a noble in Russia. So, he's
about 1/8 black, and he's very proud of
it. And so, what's important for us to
remember is again, for most of of human
history, race was not a concept. Okay?
People didn't really care what race you
were.
Um
This is Anton Chekhov who is considered
the greatest short story writer in human
history, okay? Uh music. Russian music
is extremely
Russian music is
is beautiful, okay?
I'll I'll play you some
uh
some clips of Russian music, okay? This
is Glinka, was a very famous composer.
The most famous composer, of course, is
Peter Tchaikovsky.
Okay? And he is famous for three ballets
that are still performed today.
Um The Nutcracker, which is performed
Christmas.
This is his most famous, Swan Lake,
okay? So, let's let's hear some music
from Swan Lake. Just so you can you can
appreciate the beauty uh and the depth
of Russian music.
What astonishing about this music is
that this music
can flow into your essence, your soul,
okay? This music comes from the soul.
And
to create music this beautiful, your
soul must suffer, okay? Your soul must
engage in misery, pain, and suffering in
order to create such beauty.
Okay? So, this is just um
uh haunting, beautiful music that
Tchaikovsky created, okay? Uh Sleeping
Beauty is also a really famous play by
um
um Tchaikovsky.
Igor Stravinsky
is considered
the first great modern composer. And he
composed something called
The Rite of Spring. Okay? This is 1913.
It was first performed in
Paris. And it was so revolutionary
that it caused a riot uh within the
music hall. Um
This
uh ballet, what it tries to do is it
tries to
fuse the pagan tradition
into modernity.
Okay? Uh I'm going to play some excerpts
from
The Rite of Spring.
And you can see
how revolutionary this music is. And And
I want And what I want you to notice is
this music expresses, encapsulates the
contradictions within Russian
civilization, between the pagan and the
Christian.
You can feel the rawness, the energy,
the violence, the aggression,
the sensuality.
Okay? So, this musical, this ballet,
it's about The Rite of Spring. So, it
goes back to a Slavic tradition where
they celebrate the mother goddess. And
in spring, so they to celebrate this
transition uh perform games and have
festivals.
And what ends
what ends the fes- fes- festivities is
the sacrifice of a maiden, okay? She
will dance until she dies.
And when she dances
to her death, her her heart will
explode, okay? And this symbolizes how
the mother goddess gives life to the
world by making
um by dancing
and
basically
um pouring out her blood into the world
in order for plants for
uh the seasons to change. And then her
heart will will explode. And in this
world, what's important for us to
understand is
it's all interconnected and it must be
balanced out and and harmonized. So, if
the mother goddess sacrifices herself in
order for there to be life, then the
maiden must sacrifice herself to thank
the mother goddess, okay?
All right.
So, now let's move on to Russian
literature. In Russian civilization,
there are two great prophets.
They are Leo Tolstoy
and Fyodor Dostoevsky. Together, they
will create uh modern Russian
civilization, the sensibilities, the
beliefs, the philosophies of modern
um
Russian civilization. And what they're
trying to do is they're trying to
reconcile the contradictions within
Russia through their uh novels, okay?
These are the great novelists
uh in the human tradition.
All right.
So, Tolstoy's most famous novel is Anna
Karenina, which is considered also um
the greatest work
uh of literature,
the greatest novel ever written, okay?
And I want to first read some passages
from Anna Karenina. This is the
beginning, okay? This is most one of the
most famous beginnings in world
literature.
Happy families are all alike. Every
unhappy family is unhappy in its own
way.
Everything was confusion in the
Oblonskys' house. The wife had
discovered that the husband was carrying
on an an intrigue with a French girl,
okay? So, what Tolstoy is telling us
from the first
couple paragraphs is Westernization,
Europeanization, it is a process of
corrupting the Russian soul.
Okay?
The idea
that you bring in a French girl and the
husband's going to sleep with her.
It's corruption.
Okay? Now, this is This is important
because the Oblonsky, the husband,
they are now um engaged in a divorce.
And Anna Karenina will come from St.
Petersburg to try to reconcile husband
and wife. And Anna Karenina herself will
commit adultery. She'll fall in love
with um a man named uh Vronsky. They'll
have a very passionate affair. And this
passionate affair will destroy uh both
Vronsky and Anna Karenina. Anna Karenina
has a husband and a child back at St. um
Petersburg. She asked for divorce. Her
husband won't give it to her. Uh and
then she slowly falls into depression.
And then she commits to killing herself,
okay? So, let's look at look at the her
the monologue
that she has within herself before she
decides to kill herself, okay? So, she's
going to explain why
she's unhappy.
My love keeps going more passionate and
egoistic, okay? Selfish. While his is
waning and waning, and that's why we're
drifting apart.
So, they've been together for a long
time, but she feels that Vronsky is no
longer as passionate as he used to be,
while she is becoming more passionate.
And there's no help for it. He is
everything for me, and I want him more
and more to give him himself up to me
entirely. He wants more and more to get
away from me. We walked to meet each
other up to the time of our love, and
then we have been irresistibly driven in
different directions. And there's no
altering that. He tells me I'm insanely
jealous, and I have told myself that I
am insanely jealous, but it's not true.
I'm not jealous, but I'm jealous
and I Sorry. I'm not jealous, but I'm
unsatisfied, okay? This is the most
important word, unsatisfied.
Okay? It tells us
that she's a very selfish person who's
using love as a way to fill the void in
her heart. She feels that this
relationship, this adultery, will give
her meaning in her life.
And what she doesn't understand is
when that happens,
when you
um try to possess someone,
you can't love that person because love
is really about um giving yourself all
to another person, okay? So, think of
think about Dante. Dante never got
anything from Beatrice, but he loved her
regardless.
Okay? So, that This is where Anna
Karenina fails. She doesn't really
understand what love is. And she's very
selfish. Also, a huge problem for uh
Anna Karenina Nina is
because she betrayed her husband,
she now fears that her that Vronsky will
now betray her, okay? So, do you see the
psychology here?
And that's why she can't she can't love.
Because she broke the fundamental
condition
for love, which is trust.
Okay?
So, this is telling us that the heart is
a mystery. It's something that that
cannot reason out. It's something that
you can never fully understand.
Okay?
In theory,
if you find someone more attractive, if
you think you're better off with him,
then you should go be with him, okay?
That's Western civilization, basically.
Pursue your own happiness.
But what Tolstoy is telling us is the
heart is something you cannot master,
okay? Maybe your mind can master, the
reason, the logic you can master, but
the human heart works by its own set of
logic.
And you must respect the human heart.
If you want to love, then you must give
and not receive.
If you want to love,
base your love on trust. Do not betray
yourself. Do not betray others, okay?
Does that make sense?
All right.
So, now let's move on to really the man
who who is at the heart and center of
Russian civilization. His name is Fyodor
Dostoevsky.
Okay? So, let me give you some
background about Fyodor Dostoevsky.
Um both Tolstoy and Dostoevsky were
extremely passionate
Christians. They really believe in They
believe in the Christianity. They And
they had deep empathy for the people
around them. Uh
Tolstoy was born very wealthy. He was He
was of the of the nobility. And he
inherited a lot of money. But because he
was so distraught by the suffering
around him, because his wealth was
basically based on the oppression of the
peasantry, right?
He actually wanted to
give up all his money. He wanted to
throw it all away and become a beggar.
He wanted to become poor. And it was
only at the insistence of his family
that prevented him from doing what he
felt he felt his heart demanded of him.
Fyodor Dostoevsky comes from the lower
nobility. His father was a doctor. Um
and as a young man, he was he was a
revolutionary. And he participated in
these um literary revolutionary circles.
He wasn't violent, but he had these
subversive ideas. So, he was He was
arrested and he was condemned to death.
He was put in front of a firing squad
uh along with with others who were part
of the subversion.
And at the last minute,
he was his sentence was commuted. He was
spared by the Tsar. He was sent to hard
labor in Siberia for a number of years.
And this was a very traumatic, but it
was also a extremely enlightening
experience for Dostoevsky. It made him
think very deeply about the meaning of
life.
Okay, so
um
he writes something called Crime and
Punishment, which is really the great
novel of of of Russian civilization. It
has to do with a man, Raskolnikov, who
he's young, he's brilliant, he's a
university student, but he's poor.
And he decides that in order to escape
his circumstance, in order to control
his fate, he's going to murder a woman,
a pawn broker, who has a lot of money.
No one likes her. No one will miss her.
And then he will He will take her money
and then build a new life for himself.
Okay? And this will be become the basis
for his greatness. And he reasons out
that, you know what? As a great
individual, as a genius, I'm going to
contribute so much to humanity. So, if I
kill a old woman no one likes, it won't
really matter, okay? So, he's been
thinking about this for like a long
time. He's all He's got it all reasoned
out. And what Crime and Punishment will
show us is
reason is nothing. It doesn't really
matter. What matters is the heart.
Okay?
All right. So,
um
first I want to talk about
Dostoevsky's understanding of God, okay?
Which is the Russian understanding of
God. So, at a bar, at the beginning of
the novel, Raskolnikov meets a
middle-aged man who's a drunk, okay?
He's He's He's an alcoholic named
Marmeladov, okay? Marmeladov.
And Marmeladov um
is extremely pitiful man.
Because what he's done is He's He's
uh He's like a middle-aged bureaucrat.
Um and he's been poor, and he marries a
poor widow as well. And they have like
four children to feed. So, the widow
decides to prostitute um Mar-
Marmeladov's daughter, Sonya,
to make money.
Okay? And then Mar-
Marmeladov, in a fit of tremendous
regret, he goes and finds a job.
And this seems like it's going to
resolve all problems in the family,
right? But he does something that no one
really could predict or expect. He
decides to steal all the men and all the
money within the household,
quit his job, and get drunk every day.
Okay?
And you hear this and you're like,
um that makes no sense. But again,
that's the beauty of Russian literature.
It's It's focused on what what drives us
psychologically. It's not about what's
reasonable, what is logical. It's really
about what we what we do in these
circumstances, okay?
And so
Mar- Marmeladov, he's driven to despair
because he he feels he sacrificed his
daughter, okay? He hates the fact that
his daughter has become a prostitute,
and he cannot allow himself and his
family to live happily ever after now
that his daughter is a prostitute. And
that's why he decides to be- become
alcoholic. And then they talk about God,
okay? They talk about God and what the
nature of God is. And this is very
important for us to understand
Orthodox Christianity.
He says to Raskolnikov, "Why am I to be
pitied, you say? Yes, there's nothing to
pity me for. I ought to be crucified,
crucified on a cross, not pity feet not
pitied. Crucify me, oh judge me, crucify
me, but pity me. And then I will go of
myself to be crucified, for it is not
merrymaking I seek, but tears and
tribulation. Do you suppose, you that
sell, that this pain of yours has been
sweet to me? It was tribulation I sought
at the bottom of it, tears and
tribulation, and I found it, and I have
tasted it. But he will pity us who has
had pity on all men, who has understood
all men and all things. He is the one.
He too is the judge. He will come in
that day, and he will ask, 'Where's the
daughter who gave herself for her cross,
come son of stepmother, and for the
little children of another? Where's the
daughter who had pity upon the filthy
drunkard,
her earthly father, undismayed
by his beastliness?' And he will say,
'Come to me. I have already forgiven
thee once. I have forgiven thee once.
Thy sins, which are many, are forgiven
thee, for thou hast loved much.' He will
forgive my Sonya. He will forgive, I
know it. I felt it in my heart when I
was with her just now. He will judge,
and he will forgive all the good and the
evil, the wise and the meek. Okay? So,
this God that the Orthodox Christian
celebrate, it's a forgiving God. It's a
merciful God. It is a knowledgeable God.
A wise God. Why? Because we humans
cannot be trusted to be wise. We humans
are
We suffer the mysteries of the heart.
We do not know ourselves. We do not know
our nature.
And therefore,
we are bound to suffer. And And God
understands this, and that's why God
will ultimately redeem us all when the
time is appropriate.
Okay? So, it's fatalistic, but at the
same time it's also optimistic.
Okay.
So, um
let us summarize what the differences
are between the Protestant, Catholic,
and Orthodox religions, okay? And again,
these are different branches of
Christianity, and they seem similar,
but in reality, they are extremely
different, okay? So, the Protestants
believe that we choose to sin. We have
free will.
The Catholics don't believe in free
will. They say we are born in sin.
And the Orthodox are fatalistic. They
believe we are born to sin. We cannot
control our own nature, okay? That's the
first major difference.
Second major difference is
only a few will be saved and redeemed,
okay? The Protestant is a very
unforgiving religion.
Only if you work hard and become very
wealthy, will you be saved. The
Catholics believe that no, everyone can
be saved and redeemed.
And the Orthodox believe we are beyond
salvation and redemption. The human
heart is so dark, so mysterious, that we
are beyond salvation and redemption. And
that That is why God is great. Because
only God can save and redeem us, even
though we are beyond salvation and
redemption. Okay?
Um the third major difference is the
Protestants believe
that our faith in God will save and
redeem us.
The Catholics believe
obedience to God Oh, sorry. Obedience to
the to the church is what will save and
redeem us. Where- Whereas the Orthodox
believe that
um only God can forgive us. And if God
forgives us, we can't really control.
All right? So, these are the three major
differences. And this is important
because the Orthodox religion is at the
heart and center of Russian
civilization.
Okay. So, let's see how this influences
Crime and Punishment.
Um so
this is a very important passage in
Crime and Punishment. And we'll be
discussing this a lot as we move on,
okay? So, here Raskolnikov,
he's killed the old lady, he's stolen
her money, but now he feels tremendous
regret. And he doesn't know why.
He can't sleep. Um
he's He He He falls into sickness. He
doesn't know why this is happening
because he's already reasoned it out,
right?
And then he meets Sonya, who again is
Marmeladov's daughter, and he and he
confesses to her what he's done. And not
only that, but he tries to explain why
he's done this, okay? This is a very
important passage in Western
civilization.
I saw Sonya that if one waits for
everyone to get wise, it will take too
long. So, he's basically given up on
humanity. Afterwards, I understood that
that would never come to pass, that men
won't change, and that nobody can alter
it, and that it's not worth wasting
effort over it. Yes, that's so. That's
the law of their nature, Sonya. That's
so. And I know now, Sonya, that whoever
is strong in mind and spirit will have
power over them. And the one who is
greatly daring is right in their eyes.
He who despises most things will be a
lawgiver among them, and he who dares
most of all will be most in the right.
So, it has been till now, and so it
always be. A man must be blind not to
see it. Okay? So, let's go back to the
French Revolution. Raskolnikov is
someone who fundamentally fundamentally
believes that everyone can be reasoned
with, that reason exists in all of us,
and if we appeal to reason, then people
will be good.
Napoleon is someone who believes that
I must lead the man.
People are weak. I must be strong.
Okay? So, what Raskolnikov is saying is
like, I killed the old lady because I'm
trying to prove that I'm Napoleon and
not Raskolnikov.
It's people like Napoleon who will
change history, who will save us.
Raskolnikov can only be sacrificed.
Okay?
And this is important because
what Dostoyevsky wants to show in Crime
and Punishment is
that this sort of reasoning, it sounds
right. But it goes against the human
heart. When that happens, when the
reason and the heart come into conflict,
the heart will always triumph. And this
can only lead Raskolnikov into misery.
Also, what will happen is that very
important
thinkers like Friedrich Nietzsche
as well as Sigmund Freud, they will read
this and interpret it in their own way.
Okay? So, Friedrich Nietzsche will read
this and think that, no, this makes
sense, okay?
Or it's not that Raskolnikov is wrong,
it's that he didn't believe this enough.
All right, so we'll talk about this next
class. All right.
So, um Raskolnikov, he's being pursued
by the police. And
it's obvious that he's the culprit. It's
obvious that he's guilty.
But what happens is someone else
confesses to the crime. And we don't
know why, but someone else to the crime.
And at this point, you would think that
Raskolnikov is now happy. He's now free
to do whatever he wants. This shows that
it is God's will that he become great.
It's God's will that he kill and become
great. But what happens next is he
decides to confess the crime.
And the confession is the confession
strikes
it's so striking and so nonsensical that
the law the legal system doesn't know
really doesn't know what to do with him.
So,
they basically sentence him to like hard
labor in Siberia for a few years. It's
it's the lightest crime. So, it's the
lightest punishment he could have ever
received, okay?
And at this point, you would think that,
okay, now he's happy with himself
because he killed someone, he felt
regret, and now he's he's doing some
punishment, and then eventually he will
be redeemed, okay? But this causes even
more anxiety in him. It causes more
confusion in him, okay?
He did not repent of his crime. He
doesn't feel guilty or remorseful for
killing the landlady, okay?
At least he might have found relief in
raging at his stupidity as he had raged
at the grotesque blunders that had
brought him to prison. But not in
prison, in freedom, he thought over and
criticized all his actions again, and by
no means found them so blundering and so
grotesque as they had seemed at the
fatal time.
In what way, he asked himself, was my
theory superior to others that have
swarmed and clashed
them
clashed from the beginning of the world.
One has only to look at the things quite
independently, broadly, and uninfluenced
by commonplace ideas, and my idea will
by no means seem so strange. All
skepticism have plenty
philosophers, why do you halt halfway?
He He doesn't really understand what's
happening.
He doesn't understand
what his problem is.
There's There's nothing wrong with his
plan. There's nothing wrong with what he
did.
And now he's being punished
for what he did. He does He cannot
escape his own reason. All right?
Now,
um
we have to go all the way back to the
beginning of this course when we
discussed Homer in the Iliad.
Remember, Achilles had the same problem.
Achilles saw the death of of his friend
Patroclus. He swore vengeance against
Hector. And then he killed Hector, and
then he started to mutilate Hector's
body.
And after he did so, you would think he
would found relief and catharsis.
But it only made him even more
depressed, more miserable.
Okay? So, this is what Homer and
Dostoyevsky is telling us. Don't try to
reason things out. You try to reason
things out, it will only make you
miserable because the truth is not
within reason, okay? The truth is within
the human heart.
"Why does my action strike them as so
horrible?" he said to himself. "Is it
because it was a crime? What is meant by
crime? My conscience is at rest. Of
course, it was a legal crime. Of course,
the letter of the law was broken and
blood was shed. Well, punish me for the
letter of the law, and that's enough. Of
course, in that case, many of the
benefactors of mankind who snatched
power for themselves instead of
inheriting ought to have been punished
at their first steps. But those men
succeeded,
and so they were right, and I didn't.
And so, I had no right to have taken
that step." It's only in that he
recognizes criminality, owning the fact
that he had been unsuccessful and had
confessed it, okay? So, he keeps on
reasoning and he decides that the source
of his misery is his weakness.
Okay?
He killed the lady, and he felt regret
for doing it. So, this proves he's not
great. Napoleon would not have felt any
regret. Julius Caesar would have laughed
about it.
Alexander the Great would have bragged
But he felt regret, and therefore he is
weak.
Okay?
And that is where his reasoning gets
him. It only makes him more miserable.
Okay, but he finds salvation and
redemption. And he finds salvation and
redemption in the love of Sonya. So,
right now, Raskolnikov he's in Siberia
in prison, and Sonya comes all the way
to be with him.
Okay? And this is this is how the novel
ends.
How it happened, he did not know, but
all at once something seemed to seize
him and fling him at her feet. He wept
and threw his arms around her knees. For
the first instant, she was terribly
frightened, and she turned pale. She
jumped up and looked at him trembling.
At the same moment, she understood, and
the light of infinite happiness came
into her eyes. She knew and had no doubt
that he loved her beyond everything, and
that at last the moment had come.
Okay? So, this is what saves him. He
love. He surrenders himself to
his love for Sonya. He surrenders
himself to Sonya.
And that's what ultimately saves him.
So, think back to the Iliad, right? What
saves Achilles? What saves Achilles is
Priam comes, kisses his hand, forgives
him,
and then Achilles surrenders himself to
Priam. They They cry together.
Okay? So,
the source of salvation and redemption
is in our hearts, not in reason.
You have to surrender yourself to your
love, either for the other people
like Sonya or to God. That's where
salvation is.
Okay?
All right. So, the other great novel of
Dostoyevsky is called The Brothers
uh
Karamazov, okay? Um
and it's much too long to read, but
there's a very important passage
it within the novel. It's about 1,000
pages called The Grand Inquisitor. The
Grand Inquisitor, he is in charge of the
Inquisition in Spain. And as you know,
the Inquisition in Spain in 1492, it is
horrific. Christians
um who have who are who have their own
ideas are being persecuted. They're
being slaughtered, okay? And it is a
nightmare. So, what happens is Jesus in
heaven, he sees this pain, he sees this
suffering, and it bothers him. So, he
descends to the earth.
And when he's he's walking among men,
and right away people recognize who he
is. They
um
worship him.
Then he's dragged before the Grand
Inquisitor. He becomes a prisoner to the
Grand Inquisitor. At this point, you
would think the Grand Inquisitor would
be happy to see his God. Instead, he
gets really, really angry at Jesus.
Okay?
"Thou did not love them at all. Thou who
did come to give thy life for them,
instead of taking possession of men's
freedom, you did increase it and burden
the spiritual kingdom of mankind with
suffering forever. You did desire men's
free love that he should follow you
freely, entice and taken captive by you.
In place of the rigid ancient law, men
must hereafter with free heart decide
for himself what is good and what is
evil, having only your image before him
as his guide. But did you not know that
he would at last reject even your image
and your truth if he is weighed down
with a fearful burden of free choice?
They will cry aloud at last that the
truth is is in you, for they could not
have been left in greater confusion and
suffering than you have caused, laying
upon them so many cares and unanswered
unanswerable problems.
Okay?
Okay, so the idea here is this.
So, one question that Jesus would have
for the Grand Inquisitor is
I sacrificed myself to free my people
to give people the free choice, free
will
to love me freely. Instead, you guys
have built this great Christian empire,
the Catholic Church, to oppress
everyone.
Why did you do that?
And the Grand Inquisitor is saying to
him, "It's because people don't want
free choice. People don't want free
will. They want to be told what to do.
And you refuse to be their king. You
refuse to be their emperor. You demand
of them that they reason, that they love
you freely. And people don't want to
don't want to do that. So, we had no
choice but to oppress people, to build a
church as a great oppressive empire in
order to liberate people from the burden
of free choice. Okay? Does that make
sense? That's the argument here.
You did come to give
Sorry.
And how are the other weak ones to blame
because they could not endure what the
strong have endured? How's the weak soul
to blame that it is unable to receive
such terrible gifts? Can you have simply
come to the elect and for the elect?
He's also saying to Jesus, "Listen.
You tell us that only by believing in
you freely can we be redeemed.
But that takes power. That takes
strength. What about those who cannot do
such a thing? How about the weak?
How about the lost? Will you condemn
them to hell?
That's not very merciful.
Okay?
Okay, so this is how the story ends.
When the Inquisitor ceased speaking, he
waited some time for his prisoner,
Jesus, to answer him. His silence
weighed down upon him. He saw the
prisoner have listened intently all the
time, looking gently in his face and
evidently not wishing to reply. The old
man longed for him to say something,
however bitter and terrible, but he
suddenly approached the old man in
silence and softly kissed him on his
bloodless aged lips. That was all his
answer. The old man shuddered. His lips
moved. He went to the door, opened it,
and said to him, "Go and come no more.
Come not at all. Never, never." And he
let him out into the dark alleys of the
town. The prisoner went away. And the
old man, the kiss glows in his heart,
but the old man adheres to his idea. All
right, so what he's saying is this.
The Grand Inquisitor, he has this
novel, he has this philosophy
of why Jesus is bad, of why we should
worship Satan, of why we need an empire,
why we need oppression. And it all makes
sense, okay?
And now Jesus must respond. And Jesus
responds with an act of forgiveness,
with an act of charity. He kisses
the Grand Inquisitor. And this is
exactly like Priam kissing Achilles.
Right?
Priam didn't go to reason with Achilles.
Priam went to kiss
Achilles' hand to forgive him.
Okay? Now, what's important for us to
understand is the kiss glows in his
heart, but the old man adheres to his
idea.
We can't change someone's reason ever.
But we can change
his heart
with an act of mercy and forgiveness and
love.
That's the secret of humanity.
They beg at you nowhere because people
are stubborn about their ideas. But the
heart, even though it's a mystery,
it's still loving. It's still
open. So, if you touch it, you change
people forever.
Okay?
All right, so let's go back to the
original question.
Why did Putin invade Ukraine? What Putin
has said over and over again is we
invaded Ukraine to save Russian
civilization. And that's the answer.
Because for the Russians, their
civilization it is unique,
it is distinct,
and it is beautiful. It's worth dying
for.
Okay? And now
Okay, so
um even though the Russian empire is
gone,
Putin
and Russians believe they are the heirs
to the empire, okay? So, let's look at
the differences between the American
civilization and the Russian
civilization to understand why this war
happened.
The
Okay, sorry. Um to be very clear, this
is how the America the Russians see the
Americans, okay? Does that make sense?
This is how the Russians see the
Americans. First of all, they see that
the Americans are extremely
materialistic.
Okay? The only thing that matters is
things, buying things, consuming things,
obtaining things.
But not only that, but the Americans
believe that this is the only good in
the world. It's universal. Everyone
Everyone wants to buy things. So, we
should just let everyone buy things.
And
the Americans are expansionist, which
means that
not only is it right and good for people
to buy things, but everyone
should have the right to buy things. So,
if you are preventing people from buying
things, you are a dictator. You are a
tyrant.
Okay? It is our responsibility to
liberate the world so we can all become
consumers.
North Korea, Iran, they all have to be
liberated so that their people can buy
things from us. Okay? So, that's the
American civilization. The Russians
think like, "No.
We are a spiritual people. We are
unique, and we demand sovereignty. We
demand the right to live the lives we
choose to live. We demand the right to
be who we are."
Okay?
And if it means
fighting America, if it means our
deaths,
if it means sacrifice, we will do so
because our civilization is the greatest
in the world. Because our conception of
God is the correct conception.
Because our truth is the real truth.
All right? So,
in other words, this is really a class
of civilizations.
And in a class of civilizations,
um there can only be one one winner.
There can be no compromise, okay? So,
this war in Ukraine, it is signaling
something much more devastating, much
more
um cataclysmic.
All right?
And so,
this is what's going on. All right.
That's it, guys. Any questions?
You guys uh
Is Is this clear to you?
All right, any questions?
About what what what what what what we
discussed?
Yeah, great. Yep.
So, right. So, you're right. So, Russian
literature is very romantic. And the
idea of romanticism, it's a response to
the Enlightenment. Or because the
Enlightenment with Kant and Rousseau,
the argument is that reason is the
ultimate salvation. Through reason, you
can save yourself and you can save
civilization, okay? If it's logical,
then it's truthful. And the And the
romantics And the idealists Sorry, the
romantics are saying, "No, that's not
true." Okay? And what Dostoevsky
Dostoevsky is saying is telling us that
is that this is nonsense. Reason doesn't
really get you anywhere. Okay? Through
reason, you can reason that it's okay to
to kill millions of people.
Okay?
Logic doesn't really get you anywhere.
What What you have to do is listen to
your heart. Okay? Think about the heart.
That's where the truth lies.
All right? So So, it's very much a
reaction against the Enlightenment in
Europe at this time.
Okay? What Dostoevsky is also saying
like Tolstoy, westernization of Russia
is only corrupting us.
What we need to do is return to our true
selves, which is an Orthodox
civilization.
Okay? Because that's that's the true
Christianity.
All right?
Okay? So,
great. Any more Any more questions?
Okay, that's a great question, okay? So,
the question And it's one of a question.
If I just said that the Russians are
fatalistic, then how are they so
resilient?
Okay? So, um
um
you can't logically figure it out, okay?
It's like I can't logically explain to
you the feeling.
But it's like knowing
that the world is doomed, okay? We're
heading towards doom.
And what we do isn't that important. It
compels you
to live your best life.
Okay? So, that's what meaning is.
Meaning is with the knowledge that
the world is ultimately headed towards
doom,
you as a person are compelled to
live your best life nonetheless.
Okay? And that's a very
um very pagan, very Viking mentality.
Okay? So, before Christianity, this was
true for for for for for people.
It's okay the world is going to end.
What matters is
the life you lead today.
Okay? So, um
um So, I mean, it's problematic because
I I mean, Americanization,
Westernization
has has such a huge impact on global
culture, right? And we think that we
think in very utilitarian terms. We
should do something because it gets us
somewhere.
Okay? And Russian civilization is it's
very much like, we should do something
because we know it doesn't get us
anywhere.
And that's what truth is. That's what
life is about. That's the meaning of
life. That's the purpose of life.
Even though you know it won't get you
anywhere, you should still do it because
that's where the meaning is.
Okay?
If you think about it,
um
um if you
if you go deeper,
then it's also like a profound
faith in God.
Okay?
Like you know the world is ending, but
you still
work hard to make it better. And that's
what faith in God really is.
Does that make sense? If you know like
if you do something and God rewards you,
that's not faith really.
Does that make sense? Okay? So, so I I I
understand
it's really hard for us to understand,
but what I'm trying to show you in this
class is it's hard for us to understand
because we think in a certain way.
And
if you think in a certain way, you have
to use logic and reason and language.
And what Dostoevsky in Toy Story is
telling us is like, that's very
limiting.
Okay? Sometimes you have to
listen to your heart.
And your heart knows,
I know the world is doomed because
because that's just reality, but
nevertheless, I have responsibility to
my children. I have responsibility to my
neighbors, to the people I love, to try
my best regardless.
And that's what faith in God, that's
what faith in each other, that's what
true love really is.
Does that make sense?
Okay?
All right. Great. Great question though.
And I'll be honest with you, I'm
confused by this as well, okay? Because
you know, I'm I'm I'm so Western in my
thinking. But I think
um
again, it's it's you've got you have to
train yourself not to be so logical at
times.
Right?
Okay?
Any more questions?
Does that make sense to you?
Okay.
Oh, great question. Why are the Russians
so pessimistic? Okay. First of all, it's
really cold in Russia.
Okay? If you're if it's cold, you're not
you're not that optimistic.
Right? Second of all,
Russian civilization is is built on
violence.
Right?
Um
The Americans basically went over and
were able to steal the the continent
from the natives. The natives didn't
really put as put that much much of an
existence. But Russia was built on
tremendous violence. Not only did the
Russians have to um get rid of Mongols,
they they have to fight the Swedes, the
Germans,
uh
the French. They fought everyone
basically. It was It was like a
never-ending process of war. And then
that and then the the conflicts within
their people. Okay? So, Russia is a very
violent society.
And so, that leads to a natural
pessimism, okay? So, another way of
saying this is
even though Russia is huge, it's not
that many resources and people people
have to fight constantly fight over
these resources. Whereas America is
huge, lots of resources, and people if
you work hard, you can obtain a lot of
resources, okay? So, that leads to an
optimistic attitude. So, the question
really isn't why Russians are fatalistic
because most people are fatalistic. The
question really is why Americans are so
optimistic.
Right?
Okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay? Any more questions?
Was this clear to you guys?
Okay? I and I I'm I know it's hard,
okay? But but I I will say like
um
Russian civilization
even though I personally would would
never want to live in Russia, okay? Um
because there's a lot of racism in in
Russia. Um
but it's it it is a
unique, beautiful civilization.
Um and and I hope that in the future you
have a chance to read Tolstoy,
Dostoevsky
um because they are really the best
novelists ever.
Okay? So, um next class we will start
the uh Germans, okay? German
civilization.